hey youtubers is Charlie so new Game of
Thrones tonight so I thought it'd be
good time to do a refresher on White
Walkers and the night's king so just
careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far this
will be a combo of stuff that we've
learned from the books and stuff that
we've learned from the show there have
been a couple changes that the TV show
has made to the portrayal of White
Walkers but only in what its omitted
thus far and what it's shown that the
books have not shown like we haven't
really seen the lands of always winter
in the books yet but on the TV show
during season four we got like a
post-credits scene during episode four
where we saw the night's king make a new
white Walker using one of Craster's
babies that's not in the books the way
Dan and Dave explained it is that they
felt like in the timeline right at that
moment that was going on in the lands of
always winter so they were just shining
a light on an area of Westeros and what
was going on in a moment that the books
had not done yet but one of the big
things that they omitted was actually in
the very first episode in the pilot
episode if you remember Game of Thrones
has an unaired pilot that they just felt
like was total [ __ ] so they had to
completely reshoot it they recast some
of the actors in part of the stuff that
they changed was in the original version
of the pilot the prologue scene with the
Nights Watch was almost like a page to
screen copy paste and they felt like the
White Walkers would be a little bit
better if they didn't reveal so much up
front like the fact that they have
language or even the look of them they
just wanted to make them a little more
terrifying this is that in the original
version of the pilot like when people
were watching the scene people who
weren't familiar with the books had a
hard time understanding who were the
good people who are the bad people
because you don't really know much about
the Nights Watch you just know they're a
group of people walking around in the
woods and you just know that the White
Walkers are this mysterious force to
kill them off so in order to make it a
little bit easier for non book readers
to understand who you're supposed to be
afraid of it took all the dialogue away
from the White Walkers and they got rid
of big close-ups like you see in
hardhome so you come away from that
scene being really scared and not
entirely sure of what you just saw
somebody killed all these people we're
not exactly sure who they are what their
motivation is and what they look like
there's a quote describing them that was
actually in the graphic novel version of
the story that just says the others are
not dead they're strange beautiful like
supernatural creatures made of ice some
different sort of life in human elegant
dangerous so you can see how it be
confused
if they made them look too pretty so
they just they wanted to make them look
a little more fearsome for the TV show
take away their ability to talk but that
doesn't mean that we won't hear them
speak at all because they do have
language even though the TV show hasn't
really made that clear in the prologue
for the first book the language is
described as Schroth which practically
sounds like the cracking of ice so if
any of you live near like a frozen body
of water you just go out and listen for
ice cracking that's what White Walkers
talking to each other sounds like but
disappointing as it may be we might
actually get a version of that before
the series is done I think we're getting
on in the episodes we're learning more
and more about them we're going to learn
more about them through brand in the
three-eyed Raven this season so I think
it's safe to say that by the time we get
to season eight we'll probably hear
their actual language in the person that
developed the Dothraki language for the
show David Peterson he actually
developed a white Walker language but
they chose not to use it on the show so
everybody's like shaking their fist like
we want to hear the language I don't
you're probably disappointed don't worry
we'll probably hear it at a certain
point if they ultimately decide to never
use it they would probably include it on
a DVD bonus feature but let's talk about
weapons whites and ice spiders so if you
don't know what the difference between a
white Walker and a white is a white
Walker is one of the sons of Craster's
that has been raised or turned by the
night's king into a white Walker and
raised in their culture they have powers
like the red priests have powers like
Thoreau Samir like Melisandre everyone's
powers a little bit different but as far
as we know all the White Walkers have
the same power and then Ice King just
happens to be the most powerful
obviously he's the leader it's not the
best analogy but think of them working
with ice you know making things objects
weapons with ice the same way the
Valyrians worked with Valyrian steel I
know a lot of people are wondering if
the night's king has a horn on his back
like oh is that the Horn of winter no
it's really just an ice plate that looks
really badass you can see a better
version of it in this behind-the-scenes
video right here we know right now that
the most effective weapons against them
or obsidian and Valyrian steel whites
are another tool that they use they're
basically like the infantry of their
army they're able to raise the dead they
reanimate corpses it's not like Thoreau
sameer or Melisandre bringing back
people from the dead
George R Martin hasn't fully explained
the mechanics of it but think of it as
someone being made whole again just you
know with pieces missing like
every time Barrington Darren gets
brought back he says he feels like a
piece of him got left behind so there's
less and less of the original version of
him but when a white Walker raises a
white they could do it to a pile of
bones thus far the red God has not been
able to reanimate anyone who hasn't been
freshly dead
the current record for red god
resurrection is three days that was Lady
Stoneheart so remains to be seen if
someone can be brought back by the red
God if they've been dead for longer than
three days as we saw during hardhome the
white walkers can also raise animals
like they're riding horses around here
there were said to be ice spiders during
the long night that was about 8,000
years ago so history is a little fuzzy
on that don't know if we'll ever see him
on the show but Dan and Dave did say
that one of the big reasons why the show
was getting hard to make was because
there were so many more special effects
that they had to do now so we'll see but
the night skank I've talked a lot about
the night's king in the past there are a
couple different versions of the night's
king the one that most people talk about
from the books is the 13th Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch who became
the first night's king when we saw him
on the TV show everyone was like is this
a version of that 13th Lord Commander is
he been alive this whole time George R
Martin clarified that know the original
night's King probably lived and died
just like a lot of the people from the
Age of Heroes
so the mythical night's king has been
dead for a long time which means that
this night's king is somebody who
probably lived recently he might even be
one of the sons of Craster we don't
really know yet when you hear the legend
of that original night's king you really
only hear that he fell in love with this
mysterious ghostly looking bride that
seemed like a white Walker she looked
kind of like a white Walker he gave his
soul to her then they returned to the
Nightfort and ruled over it like a king
and queen and started turning other
people into white walkers it wasn't
until bran the breaker in the
king-beyond-the-wall of that time named
your man which will make people's ears
prick up because wait the Horn of your
man is supposed to be the Horn of winter
was it the same person that used the
Horn of winter according to the legend
there peoples came together to defeat
the night's king and his army of white
walkers but remember there might be a
lot of aspects of history that get bled
together like if your mother and father
told you a bedtime story as a child they
might have changed small details now
just imagine that happens over 8,000
years the story gets changed again and
again and again and again until it's
completely unreliable so take it with a
grain of salt really what I'm expecting
from them these
season is just to see their army get
bigger see them get closer to the wall
and see brand learn more about them with
the three-eyed Raven most of the battle
scenes we see in the trailer I think are
going to be with the big balazar later
in the season so if the White Walkers do
make their way to the wall I don't think
it's going to be to like the very very
end and it'll be like a season 7 teaser
thing where it's like oh we're really
screwed now let me know in the comments
though when do you think that will
finally see White Walkers south of the
wall fighting against you know whoever's
left in this battle that Ramsay is
trying to fight in the north so if you
guys didn't know we're finally going to
see Branigan tonight's episode we'll
have all kinds of stuff to talk about
I'll be posting my episode 2 video after
the episode airs so be sure to subscribe
to get it
there is a new round of the giveaway
that started now - if you didn't see my
last video all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video it's just a $20 Amazon
gift card the giveaway will stay open
until I post my Q&A video later this
week why you guys wait for my video
tonight you can click here for my white
Walker behind-the-scenes video it's just
like a more complete version of what the
show does with the characters and you
can click here for my episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you